they're trying to force you out yes not
only the coach but the other two or
three guys there around
the club
at the senior executive level yes that I
felt betrayed
and you think they're trying to get rid
of you honestly I shouldn't say that I
don't know but listen I I don't care I'm
always people should listen the truth
yes I feel betrayed and I felt that some
people that don't want me here not only
this year but last year too
I don't know what's going on but since
since the Sarah Alex Ferguson left I saw
not evolution in the club the progress
was Zero
for example you have a interesting point
that how the club as Manchester United
after suck
um Ollie they buy they bring sport
directive Ralph regnick which is
something that nobody understands this
guy is not even a coach
a bigger club like Manchester United
bring sport directive surprise not only
me but all the world you know nothing
changed surprisingly natural only the
pool the jacuzzi even the gym
even some points of Technology the
kitchen
the chefs which is I appreciate lovely
lovely persons they stop in a in a time
which is
it surprised me a lot I thought I will
see different things different as I
mentioned before technology
infrastructure but unfortunately we see
many
things that I'm used to see when I was
20 21 23 so surprised me a lot